how's it going bros my name is Pippa
there are some videos online that you
should just not watch they will scar you
for life it's just not worth it this is
not one of those videos although YouTube
seems to think differently so someone
got a PewDiePie butt tattoo made but
it's buried it's nowhere to be fine I
don't appreciate this kind of censorship
coming from you oh wait there it is
let's watch
[Music]
[ __ ] add wait a minute so he has to
get a pretty pie tattoo what what did
the guy who lost the bed have to do then
I don't understand it's max
max what are you doing it's max groping
his dick I swear I've seen a porno start
just like this it will be if it's the
same as the porno that's an excellent
choice my friend that blue is gonna it's
gonna pop oh my you know the guys is
like touching as little as possible you
know he had to shave his ass just to do
this tattoo sake but it's wrong with
this guy
I'm not gonna lie that's a pretty sweet
ass I would spank that [ __ ] too
now that that's the face of someone
about together put a pie tattoo on his
ass pure joy I don't understand what's
wrong with these people
[Music]
that's a nice ass come on you too mate
see now I'm jealous how much I got to
pay for pinkeye to get me a butt tattoo
that looks mmm oh that looks good
yeah nice close-up thank you for that oh
god what the [ __ ] I never seen someone
so stunned over a brofist like she
should be more surprised that there's a
guy's ass in her face but what do you do
you know what if you ever want to get a
PewDiePie tattoo make sure it's on your
ass because I will brofist it if you
show it to me
although the PewDiePie logo its
trademark copyrighted so technically
he's not allowed to do that so I think
it's only fair that I get to personally
do the laser tattoo removal treatment I
think that sounds like a good deal I
want to say check out filthy Frank but I
honestly don't think that's a good idea
but thanks for watching this video gets
go get some butt tattoos who's stopping
you live your life be free and as always
what is that
what was that that must have been a fish
there must have been an octopus oh it's
a tiny penis